uns droht ein vernichtendes desaster
dass kessler syndrom dabei werden alle
räumfahrzeuge und satelliten rund um die
erde zerstört denn da oben kreist eine
zeitbombe über uns weltraumschrott kann
die globale katastrophe aufgehalten
werden deswegen will die europäische
raumfahrtagentur esa jetzt eine
historische mission staaten der
weltraumschrott soll eingefangen werden
gelingt das klicks umsatz im future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ja nicht so
[Musik]
übrigens ist inzwischen auch ein
populärer ist als podcast in deutschland
platz 37 das heißt wenn er tricks um als
podcast hören wollt dann geht hier oben
auf sie
es sind teile von raketen verlorenes
werkzeug oder abgeschaltete und in
aktive satelliten fest steht es ist eine
riesige menge an schrott die da über
unseren köpfen im weltraum herumfliegt
es handelt sich um mehr als 30.000 müll
teile die mindestens zehn zentimeter
groß sind diese schwirren teilweise mit
einer geschwindigkeit von 28.000
kilometern pro stunde durch den orbit
hinzu kommen noch etwa eine million
teilchen die eine größe zwischen einem
zentimeter und zehn zentimetern
aufweisen und es werden immer mehr
denn in einem pas kaden effekt entsteht
bei zusammenstößen immer neuer
weltraummüll dass kessler syndrom hat
begonnen und wir wissen dass solche
vorgänge exponentiell verlaufen ist es
also schon zu spät dazu holger krag von
der european space agency esa die
trümmer menge wächst jedes jahr gewaltig
das muss man sich mal vorstellen seit
1957 als der erste satellit mit dem
namen skotnik gestartet war sind rund
10.000 erdtrabanten also satelliten
gestartet mehr als die hälfte sind immer
noch im weltraum unterwegs und davon
wiederum die hälfte als reine wracks und
es nimmt kein ende fachleute befürchten
dass sich die zahl in der nahen zukunft
sogar verfünffachen könnte ganz vorne
mit dabei allen masc mit seinem
unternehmen spacex und seinem satelliten
netzwerk starling dass die gesamte erde
umspannt
soll aber auch andere privatfirmen sind
dabei und schießen ganze schwärme von
satelliten ins all
dort drohen katastrophale
massenkarambolagen und das sogar wenn
nur ein prozent der geräte havarieren
würde eine echte bedrohung dazu esa chef
jan wörner
stellen sie sich vor wie gefährlich das
segeln auf hoher see wäre wenn alle
schiffe die in der geschichte jemals
verloren gegangen sind immer noch auf
dem wasser treiben würden das ist die
aktuelle situation im orbit und es darf
so nicht weitergehen
zudem ist klar dieser weltraumschrott
braucht keine besondere größe um
gefährlich zu sein ganz im gegenteil
denn die enormen geschwindigkeiten mit
denen der weltraumschrott unterwegs ist
die sorgen für seine enorme
zerstörungskraft nicht nur für
astronauten astronauten im all unterwegs
sind wird das zur gefahr
die teilchen können auch einfach nur die
empfindlichen sonnensegel der satelliten
schwer beschädigen und das kann für das
leben auf der erde empfindliche
einschränkung und störung bedeuten denn
wir sind von diesen daten aus dem
weltraum inzwischen abhängig wir
benötigen sie für alles was unser leben
ausmacht nicht nur bankautomaten
navigationssystem und computer sondern
auch lieferketten und tankstellen sind
auf diese signale aus dem weltall
angewiesen es ist nicht weniger als
unsere gesamte weltwirtschaft die von
einem funktionierenden satellitensystem
abhängig ist die müll teile gleichen
geschossen die um die erde fliegen und
so gefährden sie auch die raumfahrt der
zukunft umso erstaunlicher dass ich erst
jetzt ein bewusstsein für diese probleme
entwickelt ganz vorne mit dabei
die europäische weltraumagentur esa sie
will den weltraum schwarz zurückholen
und in der atmosphäre verglühen lassen
das budget für dieses projekt mit
vorzeigecharakter 100 millionen euro mit
dabei das schweizer startup ihr space es
zusammen ergibt sich so die erste
weltraum müllabfuhr überhaupt fachleute
sprechen statt von einer weltraum
müllabfuhr lieber von active die berufe
also aktive trümmer entsorgung space 1
jedenfalls soll in fünf jahren 2025 ins
all starten und dort defekte satelliten
und größere trümmer einsammeln das soll
mit hilfe der greifarm des abschleppers
funktionieren das erste projekt ein 112
kilogramm schweres raketen teil der esa
das in einer höhe von 600 kilometern
über uns kreist und das seit etwa sieben
jahren 2000
dieses modul soll der abschlepper dann
in richtung der erde ziehen in der
atmosphäre soll dann nicht nur dieser
weltraumschrott sondern auch das
abschleppen modul vergnügen auf den
ersten blick klingt das ziemlich simpel
ist es aber nicht denn die technik für
diese mission ist nicht ohne dazu
schreibt die esa auf ihrer website dead
space jäger muss das objekt mit hilfe
von sensoren orten präzise ansteuern und
sich so weit nähern dass die greifarme
und das trümmerteil einfangen können
ohne jedoch mit ihm zu kollidieren
schwierig wird es bei objekten die
unkontrolliert rotieren klar sind solche
rondo manöver im all
mittlerweile nichts neues mehr doch
bislang schafften es die raumfahrzeuge
nur an entsprechend konstruierten
stellen anzudocken anders bei case man
diese weltraum müllabfuhr kann auch
unkooperative objekte greifen allerdings
ist natürlich auch dafür absolute
präzision notwendig so wird der
weltraumschrott stück für stück aus der
erdumlaufbahn entfernt und die gefahr
weiterer kollision sinkt auch das risiko
für aktive satelliten nimmt so ab dazu
holger kraft der leiter des programms
weltraum sicherheit der esa wir müssen
aktiv werden wenn die umlaufbahn der
erde nutzbar bleiben sollen das wurde
beispielsweise im herbst 2009 10 klar
als sich einer der styling satelliten
von spacex auf kollisionskurs mit dem
esa forschungssatellit befand tausende
von schrott teilchen wären entstanden
wenn der crash nicht verhindert worden
wäre ein ähnlicher fall anfang dezember
diesen jahres 2020 hier war es eine
chinesische raketenstufe die den ice
beobachtungs satelliten der esag rosa
tutu drohte ein tonnenschweres schrott
teil das seit dem jahr 2016 mal
unterwegs war befand sich also auf
kollisionskurs mit dem esa satelliten
esa fachleute haben den satelliten dann
beschleunigt und ein ausweichmanöver
durchgeführt noch einmal glück gehabt
also doch mittlerweile gibt es alle paar
tage alarm und künstlichen erdtrabanten
müssen vor weltraumschrott geschützt
werden der plan der esa ist es vor allem
die technologie für solch eine
aufräumaktion so liefert und zudem auch
zu zeigen dass solch eine art der
weltraum müllabfuhr funktionieren kann
dazu sagt holger krag künftige missionen
müssen so geplant werden
kein weltraummüll mehr entsteht wer
seine mission nicht nachhaltig plant
muss künftig für das aufräumen bezahlen
die esa will die technologie dafür
liefern und zeigen dass es geht wir
wollen den stein ins rollen bringen
langfristig sollen dann natürlich auch
missionen staaten die deutlich
anspruchsvoller sind und mehrere objekte
gleichzeitig anfangen und für einen die
orbiting sorgen sollen laut der
weltraumagentur esa könnten sich solche
reinigungsprodukte als zukunftsmarkt
herausstellen auch wenn es jetzt noch
keine konkreten gesetze gibt die dazu
verpflichten den verursachten
weltraumschrott wieder zu entsorgen doch
esa-generaldirektor jan wörner steht
genau so etwas vor er fordert dass alle
die demnächst einen satelliten ins all
schießen wollen einen vertrag
abschließen müssen daran sollte
festgehalten werden wer die beseitigung
bezahlt und welches unternehmen den
weltraumschrott bei bedarf wieder
zurückholt viele weitere fachleute
weltweit fordern eine weltraum
reinigungs gebühr die die betreiber
gleich beim staat zahlen müssen
damit könnten dann später die
aufräumarbeiten finanziert werden eine
andere idee ist es jeden satelliten mit
einem zweiten antrieb auszustatten der
eintrag im fall der fälle in richtung
erde bewegen kann damit dieses dort
sicher vergnügt doch all diese
möglichkeiten funktionieren nur wenn
alle mitmachen es hilft nicht wenn jede
nation die das unternehmen das machen
was gerade passend erscheint doch von
solch einer ordnung im all
da sind wir weit entfernt der weltraum
ist weitestgehend ein rechtsfreier ort
und das ist fatal es gibt kaum
verbindliche regeln an die man sich zu
halten hat fachleute plädieren schon
seit langer zeit für mehr kooperation im
visier der mitgliedsländer von eu und
esa eine art globales fluglotsen system
fürs alter china russland und die usa
sträuben sich denn natürlich ist das
auch ein schauplatz militärische
aufrüstung und seine geheimen vorhaben
offen zu legen
daran hat keinen der großen weltmächte
ein größeres interesse und so schauen
diese auch mit misstrauen auf die
weltraum müllabfuhr der esa denn kers
pace wird hier als julius gesehen eine
technologie die nicht nur in friedlicher
absicht sondern auch in militärische
absicht eingesetzt werden kann
klar wer in der lage ist seinen eigenen
satelliten zu entfernen kann dies auch
bei einem fremden spionagesatelliten
die esa mit einer transparenten
kommunikation das misstrauen zerstreuen
und alle entsorgungs manöver im vorfeld
ankündigt mittlerweile ist die esa auf
dem weiten feld der abwracker nicht
alleine auch asien spät mit das
unternehmen as to scale bastl gerade an
einem abschnitt modul das schrottteile
mit hilfe eines magneten einfangen soll
bis zum jahr 2026 soll so eine
raketenoberstufe entsorgt werden es
kommt also ein wenig bewegung ins thema
allerhöchste zeit denn viel zu lange
haben alle weggeschaut dazu der us
raumfahrt experte pro jahr bei der
weltraum verschmutzung war es wie bei
der ozean verschmutzung alle konnten das
problem aber keiner wollte den ersten
schritt machen
das ändert sich nun denn noch bis
irgendwann ein wenig ordnung in den
weltraum einkehrt werden noch viele
jahre vergehen selbst wenn zeitnah mit
dem aufräumen punkt voran kommen würde
dazu sagt der esa wissenschaftler holger
krag wir müssen heute aktiv werden ohne
selbst direkt davon zu profitieren es
geht darum dass unsere enkel auch in 50
jahren noch raumfahrt betreiben können
ohne durch die mühle den wir
hinterlassen haben daran gehindert zu
werden wie solche schäden konkret
aussehen das zeige ich in diesem video
die größte gefahr im weltall kann sie
beseitigt werden also drauf klicken hier
anschauen und abonnieren ich freue mich
wirklich über jeden und jede die diesen
kanal abonniert wir geben uns hier
wirklich sehr viel mühe um möglichst
aktuelle themen grundlegend und
verständlich zu erklären wenn er das
öfter haben wollt dann abonniert doch
bis dahin bleibt dran